let's say you're in some type of a
strange casino that has strange casino
games and you approach a table and on
that table there's a bag there's a bag
and the gentleman I guess who runs the
table that looks more like a vase in a
bag but you get the general idea he says
well this is an interesting game what I
have here is an empty bag I'm going to
place some marbles in that bag and he
shows you the marbles they're identical
marbles except for the color so there
are five green marbles or three green
marbles and two orange marbles and you
watch the guy actually stick them in the
formerly empty bag so one two three
green marbles and two orange marbles one
two orange marbles and he says this game
is all about picking out to green
marbles so what you're going to do is
you're going to put your hand in your
not going to be able to see what you're
doing all the marbles feel exactly the
same and you're going to try to pick out
a marble if the first marble is green
you're still in the game then you're
going to try to pick out another green
marble if the second marble you pick out
so the first probably going to take it
out you're going to put it on the table
and then you're gonna put your hand in
the back again and try to pick out
another green marble if that's green as
well if you get two green marbles then
you are going to win you are going to
win one dollar he says well this seems
like an intriguing game something that's
not too difficult to play might be a
little bit of fun but how much does it
cost to play the game and the gentleman
says it will cost you it will cost you
35 cents thirty-five cents to play so my
question to you is is this a good game
to play is it rational for you to pay
thirty-five cents to play a game where
if you pick out the two marbles in this
way to green marbles that you will
actually get a dollar so let's think a
little bit about the events that need to
occur so you need the the first marble
is somewhat easy to think about or we
thought about it in previous videos what
is the probability of the first marble
I'll say the first M being green that'll
be my little shorthand what's probably
the first marble being green well what
are all of the equally likely outcomes
here well you could pick any one of
these five marble there
equally likely they all feel the same
you can't tell the difference while
you're kind of rummaging around in that
bag so there's five equally likely
outcomes and how many of those outcomes
satisfy this criteria that the first
marble is green well three of them do
there's three out of the five marbles
are green so you have a three-fifths
probability that the first marble will
be green now that's not how you win the
game the game the first marble has to be
green and the second marble has to be
green so let's think about that a little
bit so we care about the probability
that the first first marble is green and
the second the second marble is green
now you might be tempted to say well
that's just going to be that's just
going to be the probability that the
first one is green times the probability
that the second one that the second one
is green up with the G therefore green
but that doesn't fully hold in this
situation this would have been true this
would have been true if these were
independent if these were independent
but remember when you take that 1st
marble out you're setting it on the
table you have changed the number of
green assuming it was green you or
regardless of what it is you've changed
the total number of marbles in the bag
and if it was Green you've changed the
number of green marbles in the bag and
so we can't think about this as two
independent events the second the
probability of the second marble being
green is actually dependent on the first
marble being green so we have to think
of this as the probability that the
first marble is green times the
probability that the second second is
green given that the first given that
the first was green this little this
little line right over here that
literally means given what's the
probability that the second is going to
be green if we can assume that the first
marble is green so what's that going to
be well we already know the probability
of the first being green is three fifths
what's the probability the second is
green given that the first is green well
if we know that the first is green that
means that one of these green marbles is
now is now gone so how many equally
likely outcomes do we have now in this
scenario given that the first
green well we have four and actually
that would be true regardless of what
the color of the first marble is we
would only have four marbles left and of
those how many meet our criteria that
the second is green well there's only
two green marbles left so there is a two
fourths probability so the probability
of the first marble being green and the
second marble being green remember this
is the case where we aren't replacing
the marble if we were replacing that
first marble if we were putting it back
in the bag before picking the second one
then we could have done this but we
aren't we are we're leaving it on the
table so the probability of both
happening is three fifths times two
fourths which is the same thing as
three-fifths times one-half which is we
could write this is 620 it's or we could
write this as three tents or we could
write this as 0.30 or we could write
this as thirty percent so you have a
thirty percent chance of winning one
dollar so now let's try to answer our
question would you want to play this
game well if you have a thirty percent
chance thirty percent chance of winning
one dollar how much are you would you
really expect to get especially if we're
to play this over and over again how
much would you expect to get every time
you play and we'll cover this in much
more depth later on in the probability
playlist the idea of expected value but
it's as simple as thinking about well
there's a thirty percent chance that I
win one dollar so I would expect to get
thirty percent of a dollar which is 0.3
o dollars or thirty cents so would you
play this what does it make sense to pay
thirty-five cents for something that has
an expected value of only 30 cents so no
you would not want to play this game but
with that said let me ask you a second
question would you want to play this
game if instead of when you take the
first marble out you just leave it on
the table if after your first pick you
put that first marble back in the bag so
that there are five marbles there for
your second pick in that scenario does
this game start to look a little bit
better and i'll let you think about that